If you've got any old lighters laying around,
get them ready, because we're gonna use
them for some mini pyrotechnic entertainment.
For this project, i'm using these cheap butane
lighters I found at a dollar store. 3 for
a buck! I'll get those out of the package,
and then volunteer this green one for disassembly.
A pair of needle nose pliers is great for
removing the valve guard, and that will give
me access to the tensioner that tightens and
loosens the valve. By manipulating the valve
counterclockwise, and much further than it
was ever intended, I can turn this little
lighter into a mini flame-thrower. This is
because a significant amount of gas is being
released now, which is obvious because of
the 12" flame shooting out. That's a foot
long flame, but be careful because your lighter
might catch on fire, and then what are you
going to do? Alright, to make a flint bomb,
I'll use my pliers to carefully remove the
striker wheel from the two plastic tabs. There's
a spring loaded piece of flint behind the
wheel, so I'll make sure not to lose it when
it comes flying out. I just need the spring
and the piece of flint, and when I'm ready,
I can stretch one end of the spring to make
a gap large enough to insert the flint. Wrapping
the spring around a couple of times ensures
the flint is held in place, and it should
look something like this. Time to light it
up. For convenience, I'm using a candle flame
so that I have both hands free to energize
the flint. It takes about 25 seconds to see
any result, but I do see it starting to glow
orange. And when it starts glowing this brightly,
it's ready for action. Just throw it on a
hard surface, and wham-o, you've got a little
mini firework. I'm not happy about how that
scorched my patio though, so I'm using a concrete
tile as my new target. This time I'll try
using another lighter to heat this piece of
flint, and I'm trying to keep it in the orange
part of the flame because that's where it's
the hottest. When it's glowing bright orange,
i've got about 5 seconds to throw it and get
the shower of sparks i'm looking for. Waiting
any longer than that could make it self destruct
before getting it out of your hands. And this
premature sparkulation results in another
scorch mark on my patio. I tried this at night,
and got some very impressive results.
I did some tests on the street, and
that made for a cool looking firework effect.
The sparks burn hot and look awesome, and
it's amazing to see how much light these flash
off. All my flint is used up now, but I still
have these lighter bodies packed full of liquid
butane .. and I'm sure there's something I
can use them for? Hmm, somehow this feels
like it could be a really dangerous idea.
Luckily, it's just sprung a leak and turned
into a dual flamethrower, but if I smash another
one down beside it, I get more of the fire
show I was hoping for. I'm gonna stand
far away for this one, because when the flame
burns through the red casing, it demonstrates
an amazing flaming fireball. Well that was
impressive. As long as you have enough lighters,
you can make a mini firework show that will
look like this. .. Or this, and this. How
about this, this and that. It only cost me
33¢ to do this flame, flash and boom. Well
that was a fun project but very dangerous
as well, so use extreme caution if you decide
to try this for yourself, or someone could
get hurt.
That's it for now. If you liked this project, perhaps you'll like some of my others.
Check them out, at thekingofrandom.com